ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะนะเรียนเรียนโอเคกลับมาเจอกับ
ครัวตตี้กับครูพี่เอ๋ในช่องคอม prensa
เบิ้ลไทยโอเค
ครูอ้วนตีค่ะก่อนที่เราจะไป
ซีรี่นี่ของเราคลิกต่อ
วันที่ก่อนค่ะอ้าวันที่ก่อนใช่ไหมครับอ่า
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ทับหายัง
วันจันทร์อยู่นะคะวันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 9 ครับเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2020  2 ครับ
2032 ตายผชเท่าไหร่คะพ.ศ
2560 ข้าครับหน้าป.ลที่ 565
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะที่เราคุยกันเวลาตอน
นี้ใช่ครับตอนนี้สหมทุ่ม
3 ทุ่ม 3 ทุ่มเขียนเลขอะไรงวดที่จะเขียน
เลข 3 แต่ไม่ใช่เลข 3 นะอ้าว
21:00 น
25 นาทีหน้าเป็นตอนตอนกลางคืนแล้ว 3
ทุ่มยี่สิบห้านาทีนะคะอ่ะคลิปที่แล้วครู
Arty  Park ครูเอ๋เอ๋กับนักเรียนไปเมือง
กาญจนะไฟการใช้ครับคลิปนี้กูแอบพากู Arty
ไปเที่ยวบ้างไปที่ไหนครับคำวันนี้ไปที่
ไหนจากกรุงเทพฯใช่มะกรุงเทพฯนี้กู Arty
ไปทางตะวันตะวันตกตะวันตกใช้กับตะวันตก
ตอนตู้ใช่ไหมคะตะวันตกก็เหมือนกันคู๋จะพา
ลงมี
นาดฮะลงใต้ลงใต้ไปจังหวัดอะไรครับโค๊ดตี้
เดี๋ยวก่อนก่อนที่จะบอกว่าจังหวัดอะไร
เนี่ยกู Arty เวลาระบบลงใต้เนี่ยคนไทยพูด
ว่าอะไรนะอ่าคนไทยจะพูดว่าล่องใต้นะล่อง
ใต้วันนี้เราจะคุยจะพานักเรียนไปล่องใต้ 5
ล่องใต้กันดีกว่าไปไกลไหมครับวันนี้ไอ้ไฟ
ไหมคิดว่าเห้ยไกลขอไกลเลยอะไร
ไกลหรือไม่ไกลเขาใครก็ได้ไม่ไกลก็ได้
ทำไมครับทำไมไปใน
เดี๋ยวกูเอาแช่สกรีนให้โอเคไหนดูสิ
อ่ะอ่ะอันนี้เป็นอะไรคะภูอาร์เตต้าไหน
ครับอ่าเห็นไหมเห็นได้ยังเห็นๆควรตีเห็น
อ้ะเป็นแผนที่ประเภทไทยครับนายกูอูอาตี้
ขยายรูปครูใหญ่ๆได้ใช่ไหมคะโอเคขยายได้
คุย
เปิดหายขยายผิดหรือเปล่าเดี๋ยวนั้นทำไม
มันกลายเป็นแบบนี้เลยนะว่าติ๊กเย่อาได้นะ
โอเค
คุยหากรุงเทพฯก่อนโอเค
ได้นะคะนักเรียนคะ
กูอะที่ขยายกูไอ้พูดนะคะครับผม
เทพนะคะกรุงเทพฯเอมออกว่าใกล้ใกล้ไกลๆก็
ไกล
เพราะว่าจากกรุงเทพไปกาญจนบุรีครูอาร์ตี้
ขับรถ 1  1 ชั่วโมงจะนะคะ 1 ชั่วโมงครึ่ง
หนึ่งชั่วโมงครึ่งพี่
ขับรถอ่ะ
กอล์ฟใกล้ใช่ไหมคะให้ครับแตกที่ครูเอกบอก
เนี่ยครู Arty จะไปที่จังหวัดนั้นน่ะใช้
เวลา 1 ชั่วโมง
โอเคใช้เวลา 10  12  12
12 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมครับ 12 ชั่วโมงก็โอเค
อ๋อครับแม่อยู่ตรงไหนลองใต้ลองใต้ล่องใต้
ได้ไหมครับโอเคงั้นเนี่ยทำไมใช้เวลา 1
ชั่วโมงทำไมใช้เวลา 12 ชั่วโมงใช่ครับ
ทำไมไม่เท่ากันทำไมไม่เท่ากันท่าน 1
ชั่วโมงนะคะ 1 ชั่วโมงโมงไปไปโดยนั่ง
เครื่องบินไปขอท่านหนึ่งชั่วโมงนั่ง
เครื่องบินไปก็ใช้เวลาน้อยใช้เวลา 1 แอบ
มองไม่อ่ะแต่ว่าถ้านั่งรถรถทัวร์รถบัส
หน้ารถบัสรถตู้ขับรถก็ประมาณประมาณนะคะ
ประมาณ
12 ชั่วโมง
12 ชั่วโมงอ่ะถ้าขับรถไปนั่งรถไป
52 ชั่วโมงนานนาน 12 ชั่วโมงนั่งอ่าน
กอล์ฟไกลใช่ไหมครับแต่ถ้านั่งเครื่องบิน
อ่านก็ใกล้
นั่งเครื่องบินดีกว่า 1 เครื่องบินดีกว่า
ใช่มั้ยนั่งรถนั่งรถก็ประมาณนั่งรถก็
ประมาณ 1,000 บาท 1,000 บาทจ่ายครับ
1,000 บาท
เครื่องบินเท่าไหร่เครื่องบินกลัวนี่ก็ผม
ว่าน่าจะประมาณ 1,500 บาทไหมโอ้ 1,500
บาทให้แล้วแต่ถึง 2,000 บาทถึง 3,000 บาท
ครับปาก
นะคะเครื่องบินเน๊าะคะ 1 ชั่วโมงแล้วก็
แพงกว่าอีก 500 บาทหรือ 1,000 บาท ok
เนาะ K  Kim จังหวัดนั้นก็คือครูอาจ
ดรีมบอร์ดอะไรครับ
จังหวัดภูเก็ต
[เพลง]
แม่ก็
ยาวยาวเลยห้วยติ๊กคิดว่านักเรียนนักเรียน
ก็รู้จักรู้จักจังหวัดภูเก็ตหน้านักเรียน
รู้จักภูเก็ตแต่บางทีนักเรียนเก่งอะไร
อะไร
แต่บางคนก็รู้จักภูเก็ตมากกว่าเรา
ไปเราเข้าใจภาษาชื่อภาษาไทย
เดี๋ยวกูแอบพาไปดูแผนที่ภูเก็ตก่อนนะคะ
ไกลจากกรุงเทพนะคะไปจากกรุงเทพประมาณวัด
ประมานมานประมาณเท่าไหร่ครับประมาณกี่
กิโลครับเออครูเอ๋ไปดูดังหน้ามาคุ่ก็งงๆ 5
ประมาณนะคะสีแดงดีกว่า
ประมาณ
800 บาทมีเว็บนึงบอก
862 กิโลเมตร
เขาอาจจะขับไปแล้วก็ขับไปเอ่อเขาไปแล้วก็
เลยขับไปแล้วก็หลง
เรื่องเป็นบอก 840 อ๋อโอเคเครื่องบินไม่
หลงแล้วเครื่องบินต้องไปลงที่ขับรถเลือก
แบบก็ประมาณนั้นนักการบวกลบเนาะบวกรถงาน
800 กิโลกรัมใช่ไหมครับ 800 กิโลกรัมนะ
ครับอ่ะกูเองไม่แผนที่อีกอันนี้เป็นเป็น
แผนที่ภูเก็ตนะคะเหมือนที่ในจังหวัด
ภูเก็ตเลยใช่ไหมครับพี่ไงค่ะ
ก็อันนี้เรามาดูก่อนก่อนที่จะไปดูรูปอื่น
นะคะก็จะมีอาจจากตรงนี้นักเรียนถ้าตรงนี้
จะเป็นอ่ะจังหวัดพังงาอันนี้เป็นตรงไหน
ครับคุณเองขีดด้วยขีดด้วยขึ้นข้างบนน่ะ
ค่าข้างบนเป็นจังหวัดภูเก็ตเนี่ยจากใกล้ๆ
กับจังหวัดครั้งงาใช่ไหมๆมีเกาะเลาะเป็น
เกาะและวิ่งอาบน้ำกรอบมีน้ำสีฟ้าดีกว่ามี
น้ำรอบปลาอยู่แล้วนะ
น้ำน้ำรักรอบๆน้ำรอบภูเก็ตก็สวัสดีต่ออะ
นกเกาะปุ๊บติดเกาะก็ต้องมีน้ำ
น้ำรอบๆอาเมื่อกี้ครับเมื่อกี้กูเอบอกว่า
นั่งเครื่องบินมานั่งเครื่องบินมาจะลงตรง
ไหนครับเครื่องบินลงตรงนี้ค่ะโอเคลงบิน
ภูเก็ต
รับพ่อลงสนามบินแล้วก็ต้องต้องเรียก Taxi
เรียกริม OC เนาะขอไปแล้วแต่ว่าจะไปที่
ไหน
รับเราไปที่โรงแรมอะไรอ่ะที่นักเรียนจอ
ไว้ที่คู่เอกจองไว้ก็ไปที่นั่นใช่ไหมครับ
ตอนกูแอบไปไม่ได้นอนโรงแรม
เว้ยกูเห็นนอนที่เรือ
เรือมีเรือให้นอนด้วยใช่ไหมครับว้าวเอกไป
ทำงานบ
ทำงานต้องนอนในเรือนะคะเนี้ยเรามาดูก่อน
กู Arty ว่าที่ภูเก็ตเนี่ยมีมีตรงไหนที่
เรารู้จักบ้างไปที่ไหนกันบ้างครับมีที่
ไหนบ้างครับอ่าเอาที่ครูเอกเคยไปนะคะอยู่
ตรงไหนอ่ะตรงไหนครับปาตอง 5 ขวดอีรู้ว่า
ถ้าไปภูเก็ตเนี่ยครูเอกก็จะต้องไปเที่ยว
ที่เอ่อชายหาดทะเลแน่ๆเลยไปหาดอะไรก่อน
ครับตัวเองกูเองเคยไปที่นี่ก็ Arty ตรง
นี้ก็ใช้หาดหรอชายหาดชายหาดชายหาดเธอไป
ที่ไหนก็ได้ครับนักเรียนไปหมดเลยครัวนี่
ก็ไปไปกับครูเอ๋วันนี้ครูเอกไปไหนจะไป
ด้วยครับแล้วก็ตรงนี้อะตรงนี้ก่อนก็ได้
ค่ะกูอีกว่าแล้วอ่ะตรงนี้เนี่ยเป็นพื้น
ที่จากอะไรนะจากอ่ะดินน่ะลงไปสเปรย์อ๋อ
ยาวลงไปในทะเลเลยใช่ไหมครับใช่ตรงนี้ก็
เป็นอะไรนะแหลมวันนี้เราเรียกว่าแหลม
พรหมเทพ 5 เป็นแหลมคือเป็นพื้นที่ที่แหลม
ลงไปแล้วใกล้ๆแหลมพรหมเทพตรงนี้ก็จะเป็น
อ่ะอ่ะค่ะในหานตรงนี้อ๋ออ๋อมีหาดในหานหาด
ในหานอันนี้ที่คุยกับใครไปนะคะตรงนี้ก็
น่าจะเป็นราไวย์เนาะเราไวย์
เป็นหาดเหมือนกันใช่ไหมครับเรียกหาด
ราไวย์
ปลาวัยเราวัยเป็นที่ๆแล้วก็เอกก็ไปตรงนี้
ตรงนี้น้ำน้ำนะเข้าไปข้างในเราก็เรียกว่า
อ่าวอ๋อ
ถ้ามีน้ำเข้าไปข้างในเรียกอ่าวแต่ถ้ามี
พื้นดินลงไปในน้ำเรียกแหลมเนื้อกายได้ก็
ตรงนี้อยู่ตรงนี้อ่าวอ้าวอะไรครับตรงนี้
อ้าวฉลองค่ะอ้าวฉลองโอเควัดด้วยนะแถวนี้
มีวัดกลัวตีจำได้จำได้ที่เอาฉลองมีวัดวัด
ที่วัดอะไรนะคะอ๋ออ้าวอ้าวฉลองกวนพี่ก็
คิดว่าวัดก็ชื่อวัดฉลองเหมือนกันมั้ยชื่อ
เดี้ยนเขาอยู่อยู่ที่เดียวกันชื่อเหมือน
กันนะเฮ้ออะไรเอาฉลองวัดฉลองอาคะแล้วก็ก็
ต้องนี้ก็จะเป็นกัดป่ะนะคะขอเออนะคะ
กะลนวูดก็มีมีเยอะนะนักเรียนแต่คู่เอก
กำลังสงสัยว่ากูอ่ะฮะป่าตองไม่เจออันนี้
หรือเปล่าป่าตอง
น่าจะปาก 2
ทั้งหมดหรอไม่เป็นไรถ้างั้นเราไปที่อื่น
ก็ได้แล้วนะน่ารักแต่ที่พี่จะพาไปแล้วก็
จะมีตรงนี้วันนี้ที่จะพานักเรียนไปดูไม่
นี่ตรงนี้อาขอตรงนี้เป็นอะไรครับเป็น
อำเภอเมืองภูเก็ตอำเภอเมืองเพแล้วก็มีตรง
นี้ตรงนี้มีรูปปั้นนะคะเป็นรูปปั้นรูป
ปั้นอะไรครับผู้หญิงสองคนมีผู้หญิง 2 คน
ผู้หญิง 2 คนอยู่ที่อยู่ที่ภูเก็ตอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวเราไปดูกันเลยค่ะนะคะตรงนี้นัก
เรียนคะในตรงนี้นักเรียนก็จะเห็นว่ามีมี
คนว่ายน้ำ
มีมีเรือใบไทยเรือนะคะ
เล่นวินเซิร์ฟนะครับ
นัดเราไปในเมืองภูเก็ตเลยกูนี่โอเคไปครับ
ไปที่ไหนก่อนครับว้าวเลยนี่เอาอ่ะมีเวลา
มาภูเก็ตต้องไปเดินดูตึกหอตึกที่อยู่ที่
ภูเก็ตมีตึกสวยๆเยอะใช่ไหมครับเป็นใช่
เป็นตึกเก่าค่ะอ๋ออ๋อครับอันนี้สวยเพราะ
เค้าทาสีใหม่มากครับกวนพี่ก็เห็นแล้วสวย
แน่แต่กลัวตี้ดูแล้วดูแล้วไม่เหมือนตึก
ที่กรุงเทพเลยครับไม่เหมือนก็ไม่เหมือน
ค่ะตึกที่เนี่ยเป็นตึกมาก้อนเมื่อก่อน
เป็นเปิดแบบคนจีนกับโปรตุเกสรวมกันอ๋อ
ก็เลยไม่เหมือนกับที่ควรพี่เคยเห็น
ก็ตึกอันนี้นะคะนักเรียนเขาเรียกว่า
พี่โนโปรตุกีสอ๋อมีชื่อด้วยนิทานอยู่
เรียกชื่อตึกชิโนที่โหนกอะไรนะครับชิโนโป
ตุฮะโอเคที่โหนกโปรตุกีสอะเคพี่โน่ก็คือ
Chinese ก็โปรตุเกสอ๋ออ๋อมารวมกันใช่ไหม
รวมกันเป็นที่โหนกโปรตุกิส
ตรงนี้กูอ่ะพี่เห็นน่ะตรงนี้จะเป็นคงโค้ง
ก็เป็นสไตล์คนจีนนะคะ
คือเป็นตึกมาสำหรับขายของแต่ว่าตรงนี้
หน้าข้างหน้าเนี่ยถ้าเป็นกรุงเทพฯข้าง
หน้าน่ะเราเดินน่ะฝนตกเราจะเปรียบใช่ไหม
คะนะครับแต่ชิโนโปรตุเกตเนี่ยเขาจะมี
หลังคาออกมา
ขอเวลาเดินก็ไม่เดินน่ะมีหลังคาฝนก็ไม่
โดนหัวคนนั้นว่าดีเลยครับดีรวยอยากไปเดิน
ก็ยังไม่เคยเดินอ่อนๆกูแอบไปภูเก็ตมาก
กว่า 10 ครั้งขอ
ไว้เคยเด้ออ่ะ
ก็
อยากไปเด้อเดี๋ยวข่าวหน้าคราวนะต้องไป
เดินครับพี่คุยอยากจะไปเดินที่สิโนโปตุ
เกสราคาด้วยนะสวยเมื่อกี้เล่าให้ดูใช้
หาดใช่ไหมคะอ่าใช่ครับมีใช้หาดอะไรบ้าง
ที่จะพาไปครับอันนี้กูแอบไปเจอใน google
มาครับเอ่อเขาเรียกว่าหาดนุ้ยอ๋ออ๋อ
ว้าวมีน้ำทะเล
กลัวตีเห็นน้ำทะเลแต่กลัวแต่ไม่เห็นคลื่น
เลยเพราะว่าเวลาไปทะเลไปทะเลก็จะมีคลื่น
ใช่ไหมค่ะแต่อันนี้ฮิมองไม่เห็นคืน
คิดว่าวันนี้ลมที่หน่อยอ๋อก็เลยมีเหมือน
กันเหมือนกันน้ำนะเข้ามาในพื้นดินนะน้อง
เหมือนอ่าวแล้วหรอ
มีหัวตีรู้แล้วเพราะว่าเป็นอ่าวใช่ไหม
อ้าวคลื่นก็จะมีไม่มากนิดนี่หน่อยมึงลาย
ก็สวยนะๆสวยเลย
[เพลง]
ครับได้แล้วแล้วนึกอะไรนะครับเอกเองอิอิ
มีนักเรียน 1 คนของกูเอ๋อยู่แถวนี้หรอ
ครับได้เวลามาประเทศไทยจะไปภูเก็ตนะคะเขา
ก็พูดอันนี้เอกไอ้เอ๋เอ๋เอ๋ชื่อคุณคุ้นๆ
ออกเขาเคยถ่ายรูปให้ดูที่นี่เขาบอกสวย
แล้วก็
เงียบ
ไม่บอกแล้วก็คือว่าไม่ไม่พูดไม่ๆเขาก็บอก
ว่าเขาชอบมีคนคนนิดหน่อยอ๋ออ๋อมีคนน้อย
ก็เลยเงียบไม่มีคนคุยกันเยอะๆเสียงดัง
นั้นเข้าแต่ที่ที่นี่เงียบๆเงียบแต่คิด
ว่าตอนนี้น่าจะไม่เงียบแล้วเนี่ย
ต่อไปต่อไปนะคะอันนี้เลยอันนี้แหลมแถว
เป็นแหลมนี่นี่ไหมครับมีพื้นดินที่ยื่น
ออกไปในทะเล
เคนี่เรียกว่าแหลกนะคะตรงนี้ตรงนี้แหลม
อะไรคะครูค่ะอันนี้อันนี้ครัวตี้คิดว่า
หลายๆคนน่าจะรู้จักแหลมนี้เป็นแหลมที่คน
ชอบไปมากชื่อแหลมแหลมพรหมเทพครับหน้า
แหลมพงษ์เทพแล้วไปดูอะไรครับตรงนี้อ้านี่
ครับดูที่กูเอกกำลังวาดอยู่เป็นพระ
อาทิตย์ครับหน้าพระอาทิตย์พระอาทิตย์สี
ส้มอาทิตย์สีส้มลงไปในทะเลเหรอครับข้อ
ตกลงไปในทะเลว่าข้าวอะที่กำลังไปบายให้ดู
พระอาทิตย์ตกที่แหลมพรหมเทพกันใช่ไหมครับ
ถ้าสวัสดีเคยไปแหลมพรหมเทพไหมคะเคยไปครับ
เคยไปแหลมพรหมเทพแล้วกู Arty เคยเห็นพระ
อาทิตย์ตกไหมคะอ่ะเคยครับไปดูพระอาทิตย์
ตกที่แหลมกรวยไหมคะสวยครับท้องฟ้าท้องฟ้า
ก็จะเป็นสีส้มสีส้มเต็มท้องสาเลยสีส้มนะ
สีส้มได้ครับ
โอเคกวนตีเธอไมค์คู่เอกไปแหลมพรหมเทพมาก
กว่า 10 ครั้งอ๋อแล้วไม่เคยเห็น
ครูเอ๋ไปไปตอนกลางคืนเหรอแล้วพระอาทิตย์
ไปแล้วไม่ใช่กูเอกไปประมาณ 15:00 น
เต็มที่บ่าย3โมงบางที 10:00 นบางทีก็
17:00 นเลยไป 18:00 น
แต่ไม่เห็นพระอาทิตย์ยังจะเมฆฮ่าๆเห็นแต่
อะไรเข้าไปตอน
10:00 นไปตอน 15:00 นพระอาทิตย์ยังไม่ตก
พระอาทิตย์อยู่บนท้องป่ายังไม่ตก
ตายไปเคยไปตอนเย็นเหมือนกันไปพระอาทิตย์
ตกรีดอกซี่แต่ว่าไม่เห็นเหมือนกันมีเมฆ
แน่แมกมาบังพระอาทิตย์อยู่เลยครับ
[เพลง]
ครูเอ๋สงสารตัวเองไม่เคยเห็น
ไม่เคยเห็นจริงๆนะคะไม่เคยเห็นพระอาทิตย์
ตกแต่เขาบอกว่าสวยมากน่าใช่ครับสวย
โอเคนะก็เห็นลบตรงนี้พระอาทิตย์ที่แหลม
พรหมเทพเดินลงไปข้างล่างได้ใช่ไหมคะใช่
ครับเดินลงไปได้และ
เดินลงไปนะคะข้างล่างได้ไอ้ครับอ๋อตอนที่
ครูแอบไปอ่ะกูอายุประมาณ
19-20 ปีครับ
21-4-21 ปีถึง 21 ถึง 21 ปี
สองปีเนาะทำงานทำงานเอาคนไทยไปภูเก็ตนะไป
เที่ยวก็เวลาตรงแหลมพงษ์เทพนักเรียนมีคน
ไทยบางคนก็เชื่อมีก้อนหิน
ไว้แล้วก็โยม
โยนลงที่ทะเล
ต้องต้องอธิษฐานอ่าว่าคิดก่อนว่าอยากได้
อะไรนะครับอ่ะโชคดีโชคดีแล้วก็โยงลงไป
เงินก็และ
ขอบาท
โยนลงไปโอเคขอให้มีแฟน
โอเคเองอันนี้เป็นเมื่อก่อนนะคะเป็นเมื่อ
ก่อนตอนนี้น่าจะห้ามโยนแล้วนะน่าใช้ครับ
ตอนนี้แหละพรหมเทพนะคะแล้วก็อันนี้ก็เป็น
กระตะน้อยนะคะกระเป๋าก็สวยมีน้ำทะเลอ่า
แล้วก็มีอีกอ่ะอันนี้กะรนค่ะปาด
ถนนอาจใช้กะรนกะรน
Arty เคยไปกะรนไหมเคยไปครับเคยไป
สวยไหมคะสวยครับคุยไม่เคยไปฮ่าๆๆๆแต่ไม่
เคยไปกะรนนะคะแต่ที่เคยไปแล้วนักเรียนรู้
จักค่ะที่ไหนครับนี่เลยค่ะที่เก็บเข็มมาก
ๆอันนี้ขนาดนี้ชื่ออะไรคะอ่าอันนี้อ่า
เป็นหากแต่ว่าเอ๊ะทำไมคนไทยเรียกว่าป่า
ไม่รู้เหมือนกัน
หากป่าตองหน้าใส่กับ
หาดป่าตอง
หาดป่าตองมีร่มเยอะแสดงว่าเราควรตีคิดว่า
มีคนมาเที่ยวที่นี่เยอะก็เลยมีร่มเยอะเลย
เห้ยเออป่าตองนี้ส่วนมากเป็นชาวต่างชาติ
เนาะป้าน้าประมาณซัก 80% เลยอ่ะว้าว
80% เป็นชาวต่างชาติโอเคญี่ปุ่นยุโรป
อเมริกาแคนาดาจีนราคาอ่ะอาจจะ 20
เปอร์เซ็นคนไทยอ๋อ
21 เป็นคนไทยคุณครูเอ๋ตอนกูแอบไปที่
เนี่ยก็มีครูเอ๋เป็นคนไทยขออยู่ใน 20
เปอร์เซ็นต์ใช่ไหมแต่ว่าที่เหลือโอ้ไม่
ใช่คนไทยและชาวต่างชาติหมดเลยใช่ไหมครับ
แล้วที่นี่แหละกูอะตีคุยมีเรื่องขำจะเล่า
ให้ฟังมีเวลาอีกหน่อยหรอเป็นยังไงอ่าคน
ไทยนะเวลาไปทะเลไปว่ายน้ำก็จะใส่เสื้อแบบ
นี้เนาะครับใส่เสื้อยืดใช่มั้ย Bye  Bye
เสื้อยืดตั้นเนอะกางเกงขาสั้นๆ
แต่คนต่างชาติเค้าจะใส่อะไรนะ
ชุดว่ายน้ำใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำทูพีซไหมอ่า Two
Piece เลยวันพี่ก็ได้
ชุดว่ายน้ำแบบนี้แต่คนไทยอ่ะเอ๊ยไม่ใส่
kuai ไปกูเองก็อายเหมือนกันตอนนั้นเด็กๆ
ก็ก็เห็นโอ้โห
ทุกคนใส่ชุดวู้เซ็กซี่
ชายก็ดูจะมาไปกับคุณป้าดู
คุณบูเอใช่มะแล้วก็นี้คุณแม่พี่สาวคุณแม่
แล้วไปด้วยกันพี่สาวคุณแม่ก็ตื่นเต้นมาก
เราก็นั่งแล้วก็ดูจนถึง 16:00 นไม่ได้ดู
ทะเลเลยดูแต่นักท่องเที่ยวได้ไหมดูๆๆเรา
ก็ไม่ว่ายน้ำนะหัวร้อน
ก็ 16:00 นเราก็ลงไปทะเลอ๋อลงไปตอนเย็น
ใช่ไหมตอนเย็นไม่ร้อนแล้วเคอะไรที่นี่
แหละชาวต่างชาติทุกคนที่นี่
มองเราบ้างโอค่ะ
ดูแล้วก็
ได้ยินก็ได้ยินนิดหน่อยอะไรนะโอ้
แฟชั่นอันนี้ไม่โอเค
ทำไมใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นลงไปเล่นน้ำทะเลใช่
ไหมครับอ่ะไว้ใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำ
aii มากมีกลัวแต่คิดว่าปกติคิดว่าคนไทย
ก็
ใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นกางเกงขาสั้นลงไปเล่นน้ำ
ทะเลลงไปว่ายน้ำทะเลจบกติใช่แบบอันนั้น
ทะเลคนไทยพัทยาบางแสนหัวหินโอเค R5 ตอง
ไม่ได้นะกูอาทิตย์ที่ไม่ใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำจะ
มีคนมองมากๆแปลกใช่มั้ยแปลก S ทำไมไม่ใส่
ใจไหมแบบว่าราคา
โอเคป่าตองแล้วเดี๋ยวเวลาเราจะบดจะไปอยู่
ที่ไหนเออมีที่ไหนนะครับอยากไปแล้วเสา
ละครไทยไปเที่ยวก็ต้องไปไหว้พระขอไปไหว้
พระกันไปไหว้พระกัน
ที่ไหนครับเมื่อกี้เราพูดถึงอ่าวฉลองวัด
ฉลองค่ะอ๋อไปที่วัดฉลองปลาเห็นไหมเป็นวัด
ใช่ไหมครับเป็นวัดที่วัดบ่เห็นไหมคะหน้า
มองเห็นครับเห็น
วัดฉลองนะคะถ้าวัดสนองสวยจังเลยสวยมากสวย
มากมีมีมีชื่อเสียงคนไทยรู้จักได้ยินโอ้ว
วัดฉลองอ๋อวัดฉลองฉลองมีอะไรครับมีอะไร
ที่มีชื่อเสียงครับที่วัดฉลองมีพระเก่งมี
พระป้าอามีพระรูปนี้ค่ะพระรูปนี้นะคะขอ
พระรูปนี้
เก่งมากนะคะเป็นพระอะไรครับมีชื่อมี
เหรียญหลวงพ่อแช่ม
เหรียญก็แชมป์คะนักเรียนอย่างรู้จักหลวง
พ่อแช่มนะมันยังไงครับไปฟังพระเอกกับครู
เรียมหรือคุ่กับคู่เล็กนะคะอ๋อ
ซีรีส์ Story ไทยอ๋อโอเคไม่ติดตามในหัว
ข้อ Story ไทยใช่ไหมจะได้รู้จักรู้จัก
หลวงพ่อแช่มมากขึ้นโอเค
แล้วก็พี่อีกไม่อีกอ่ะกูไปไหว้พระแล้วใช่
ไหมคะไปไหว้พระแล้วไหว้พระแล้วต้องไปกิน
ครัวที่กำลังจะบอกเลยว่ะโหไปเที่ยวทะเลไป
เที่ยววัดมาแล้วตอนนี้หิวแล้วหิวแล้วงาน
จริงๆอาหารภูเก็ตอร่อยแล้วก็เผ็ดๆนะคะแต่
ว่านักเรียนอาจจะกินเผ็ดไม่ได้กูเอกก็เลย
แนะนำอันนี้ค่ะเหนื่อยแนะนำอะไรครับอัน
นี้น้ำมันหอยทอดนะคะแล้วก็มีสะปำอ้ามี
สะปำโอเคที่มีหมู่บ้านหนึ่งในภูเก็ตชื่อ
สะปำนักเรียนก็ไปแล้วก็กินหมี่สะปำ
กับนี้นะค่ะแล้วก็กินหอยทอดอันนี้ไม่เผ็ด
รอยหมาว้าวไม่เผ็ดงานกินได้ไม่ค่อยก็ได้
อีกนิดๆ
โหอันนี้อะไรครับลมกลมๆไข่มุกค่ะอ๋ออ๋อ
ไข่หมูมากมีไข่มุกขาย
ผู้หญิงชอบ
สวัสดีชอบไหมกลัวตี้เฉยๆนิดนึงชอบนิดนึง
อีกจะชอบไอ้วุฒิโอเค
แล้วก็นี้ค่ะมะม่วงหิมพานต์อาหมออ๋อนี่
มะม่วงหิมพานต์คั่วติ๊กก็ชอบกินชอบกิน
มะม่วงหิมพานต์ 7 อร่อยค่ะ
โอเคก็อันนี้คือที่ภูเก็ตนะคะเจ้าไปแล้ว
เราจะไปเที่ยวที่ไหนไปซื้ออะไรปวดแล้ว
เนาะอ่าแล้วอ่ะวันที่คุยลืมอันนี้คืออะไร
ครับอ๋อที่นี่ถ้าจะไปภูเก็ตอ่ะถ้าใครที่
ขับรถไปจะตั้งต้องผ่านที่นี่ก่อนแน่นอน
ตรงนี้เป็นภูเก็ตใช่ไหมตรงนี้เราเรียกว่า
อะไรคะตรงนี้เป็นสะพานสะพานก็จะมีสะพาน
เก่าตรงนี้เนาะ
ได้ครับมีสะพาน 2 สะพานคู่กรรมทำอันนี้ไป
สะพานใหม่อันนี้เป็นสะพานเก่า
สะพานสารสิน
ในครับตรงนี้มีเรื่องโรแมนติกคะนักเรียน
เสื้อ
ของผู้ชาย 1 คนไม่อยากฟังอยากฟัง
น้องไป Series กับครูเรียมหรือคุณนิคนะคะ
ออนจะคุยกับครูเรียมหรือครูนิรักต้องไป
Series เอ่อเรื่องเล่าไหมครับเรื่องเล่า
ในประเทศไทยโอเคจะมีเรื่องเกี่ยวกับสะพาน
สารสินนี้ใช่ไหมครับใช่แต่ถ้าไปเที่ยวครู
เอกกับกูอะตี้จะพาไปเที่ยวนะคะโอเคดีเท
ค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักภูเก็ต 5 นาย
ครับอาจจะรู้จักนิดหน่อยเนาะไม่ใช้มากๆนะ
คะเราก็อยากจะชวนนักเรียนมาเที่ยวภูเก็ต
เหตุกันนะครับวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว High
แล้วหมดเวลาแล้วก็ถ้างั้นบทเวลาแล้ว
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าครับคราวหน้านักเรียนกลับ
มาฟังคุ่กับครัวตี้ขอเล่าเรื่องจังหวัด
ต่างๆในประเทศไทยกันอีกนะใครฆ่านะคะแล้ว
พบกันใหม่อาทิตย์หน้าค่ะค่ะดีโอเควันนี้
กลัวตีกับครูพี่เอ๋ลาไปก่อนนะครับนะฮะ
สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋ดีค่ะบ๊ายบายทุเรียนไวท์
บายโอ